how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we have a
lot of exciting and
very important news to break down
there's a new team
coming to the mcu but not just any team
a very
very specific team that has been
introduced in marvel comics for a very
specific purpose
and this team is going to bring very
very important characters to the mcu
characters like the fantastic four
the x-men and other mutants as well so
in this video we're going to talk about
this new avengers team
why they are formed in the comics and
why they're going to be formed in the
mcu
and also of course how they're going to
be brought into the mcu which will
introduce the x-men and fantastic four
so we'll break all of this down but
first if you're new be sure to subscribe
to stay up to date on all things
relating to the marvel cinematic
universe and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
hawkeye
funko pop all you gotta do to enter
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment about the video down below
so if you caught my video yesterday you
know that marvel studios is planning on
bringing
the illuminati into the mcu this is
actually something that i first reported
back
in january of this year and it's a
really big deal and we're going to go
into a lot of detail that we didn't go
into yesterday but yesterday the
illuminati did report that they have
seen
a casting list for marvel studios's
illuminati confirming that not only are
they coming but they are in
pre-development
and the biggest things that you need to
know about this group are who they
are because they are very specific
people and why they are formed in the
comics so in the comics the group
is formed by iron man tony stark forms
the group and he hand
picks the members and those members are
of course himself
doctor strange black bolt namor the
submariner
mr fantastic and professor xavier and
something
important to note that i think is going
to play a part in the mcu is that he
initially asked black panther to be a
part of the group as well but black
panther declines
so this is literally a super group one
of the strongest groups ever assembled
each person very specifically picked
because they were in charge of their own
group
tony stark leads the avengers professor
xavier leads the x-men mr fantastic
leads the fantastic four
black bolt leads the inhumans doctor
strange is the sorcerer supreme
controlling the realities
and namor is the king of atlantis so the
illuminati is essentially
the leaders of all of the superheroes in
the world and when i say
the world i do mean the actual planet
earth because that is why the illuminati
were formed to protect
the earth and here's something that you
must know about this group and is going
to be very important in the future
the illuminati was formed after the
events of the cree scroll
war iron man suggesting forming a mega
group in case
other events such as the crease girl war
or any other
major power threatened earth this group
is a
secret organization controlling all of
the different superhero groups
these superhero leaders control all of
the other superhero groups and shape the
status of the superhuman world and the
world around it
so this group the illuminati essentially
controls
all of the superhero groups on the
planet and they do this so all of the
heroes can be
in sync and they can prepare for and
defend the earth in case of an invasion
or an attack
so now the question is why are they
going to be formed in the mcu
well as i mentioned in the comics
they're formed after the cree skrull war
a very big
event and we just had our very own big
event in the mcu and that of course was
avengers infinity war and avengers end
game
thanos decimated not only half of the
world but half of the universe
and then after that the 2014 thanos
almost eliminated the entire universe
after avengers end game the world does
need a super group more than
ever now now there was one attempt at
forming a super group to control the
events around the world and that was
during captain america civil war
the avengers were essentially taking
care of all of the worldly threats
but then thunderbolt ross wanted to
control the avengers control
the super people himself to where he
could use them to do whatever he wanted
them to do
and we all know how that ended because
we've all seen civil war but the fact
that the illuminati are coming now kind
of gives us a feel of what the world is
like
after the events of in-game spider-man
far from home delved a little bit into
what happened after what they called the
blip
but they didn't really focus on it too
much and when they did it was kind of
more of a comedy thing than an
actual real thing the world is obviously
going to be
incredibly different after all these
events have taken place
they now know that they're open to
extraterrestrial attacks
and now the avengers know that they can
if they're separated
lose they lost to thanos and they lost
because they were separated they could
have probably defeated him
if they were all together but it was the
avengers who managed to undo all of the
events that thanos did and then defeat
thanos not the government
the avengers are the ones who figured
out time travel they're the ones who
went back in time
and then they're the ones who defended
the earth and defeated thanos
so now it's fairly obvious that the
world after avengers in game needs to be
ran
by super people and not the government
the government with their armies and
navies can't take down people like
thanos
and they will have absolutely no luck
with future threats such as galactus or
king the conqueror the only people who
can stand up against evil threats like
these are
the superheroes the avengers the
fantastic four and the x-men but if
there's one thing that we learned from
infinity war is that all of the groups
have to be united and that's why the
illuminati is coming in
if all of these different superhero
groups are doing their own
separate things it doesn't really work
we learned that from avengers infinity
war so what
the illuminati is formed for is they
make decisions and then relay those
decisions back to their superhero groups
and they act accordingly and
together what is essentially happening
is a government for
the superheroes it's a leadership
organization controlling
what they take action on to protect the
earth and
not to mention tony stark is now gone he
sacrificed himself to save
the universe but he's gone now and he
was a really big part of the earth's
defense he had his iron legion and he
basically funded the avengers and that
also leads us to a hole in the
illuminati there's one slot that needs
to be filled and the most likely person
that they will fill this slot with is
black panther now like i said originally
in the comics tony stark asked black
panther to join the illuminati but he
said no but the events in the mcu are
obviously different and they obviously
don't adapt the entire story of the
comics and just put it on screen
and after the events of infinity war and
the events of in-game it's probably
pretty clear to t'challa that the world
needs superheroes to protect it
and not to mention the avengers are
probably going to need some funding
yes stark industries can continue to
fund the avengers but they're going to
need somebody hands-on and black panther
is perfect for that because not only
does he have the means to fund the
avengers and any other superhuman group
for that matter
but he also has the technology tony
stark didn't just provide money but he
provided technology and weapons and
suits as well
and these are all things that black
panther and shuri can provide
so in the mcu black panther can step up
and take tony stark's spot
the inhumans are still a pretty big
question mark as far as the mcu is
concerned we have a few rumors but we'll
have to wait and see on them
of course doctor strange is going to
play a big part in the mcu moving
forward
and we know that the x-men are coming
along with the fantastic four so
professor xavier and mr fantastic will
join us pretty soon and that leaves us
with
namor now there's been a ton of talk
about namor coming to the mcu
specifically
in black panther 2 but what's
interesting about this is that he will
most likely be
the villain of black panther 2. atlantis
and wakanda do have a history of
fighting each other in the comics and it
was a pretty big battle one that pretty
much decimated wakanda so
if neymar is the villain of black
panther 2 it'll most likely be somewhat
of a batman vs superman situation they
fight at first
until they have a common enemy and then
fight together namor is a really really
big character that marvel studios has
actually hinted at in the mcu a few
times with different easter eggs
including the most recent one in
avengers in-game which the writers did
confirm
was in fact a name or easter egg so we
know that he's not going to be a villain
throughout the mcu but will in fact be a
hero eventually
so hopefully in the mcu name war will go
on to take his spot with the illuminati
now what's truly awesome about the
report that we got yesterday from the
illuminati.com
is that they say based off of what
they've seen the illuminati is most
likely going to come in phase five
and phase five is only probably about
two two and a half years away
and since professor xavier the x-men
leader and
mr fantastic the leader of the fantastic
four are in the illuminati
that means that the x-men and the
fantastic four
should be introduced into the marvel
cinematic universe within the next two
to two and a half years
and this is a bit earlier than most of
us expected
there are definitely going to be mutants
in phase 4 but we weren't expecting the
actual
x-men team the fantastic four could also
make their mcu debut in another film but
not get their own movie until later on
but the illuminati coming to the mcu
means that marvel does have pretty big
plans for them and they're going to
happen relatively soon
now the original exclusive report that i
reported back in january from mikey
sutton says that we'll see the
illuminati form and doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness now it's not
going to be a prominent part of the
movie
but it could show up at the very end or
in a post-credits scene so they're going
to be set up in phase 4
and the x-men and the fantastic four are
definitely going to be mentioned in
phase 4 and then later on they'll all
debut
so the mcu is getting very very exciting
and it looks like it's going to be
changing a little bit which is to be
expected after avengers end game there
definitely is going to be a different
tone
moving forward and the illuminati are
coming to join
all of the different superhero groups
together so really exciting stuff
everybody but let me know what you think
about this news in the comments down
below how excited
are you for the future of the mcu the
x-men the fantastic four
namor and the illuminati let me know
down below and don't forget to like this
video and subscribe
so you don't miss any videos about
marvel also if you love g fuel and
energy drinks don't forget to use code
cosmic
gfio.com for live updates you can follow
me on twitter and instagram and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof